nell'episodio precedente di isaac con
marco marino posso usare il mio
preferito almeno certo è il più forte
vai ora parlo io non so chi sia grazie
vasco visto il danno il mio problema è
la gente che mi ammazza poi ucciderla
primo tumore ha fatto fallo non sono
arrabbiato addosso ai veramente urlato
fortissima laude concluso allora blu
questi in questioni di cuore
capisco lo perdi un cuore interno
contentissimo di questa volta ai danni
[Musica]
ha detto king era usato non ha usato i
fondi musica
però non si ricarica qualcosa lo so io
morirò tantino cuore nero
[Musica]
rho mi piace sia volta ai box subito si
aspetta se fare sotto terra
ora non gli ha fatto niente
ora bromwich questo dal cio che viene
adesso
intanto ha fatto saltare tutto perché
qui non c'è del negozio senza
potenziamento di co2 prodotte nei
racconti dai sono contentissimo sfida
può essere spie
pavia gol o no ma quale apre questo
esplodono e non si vede neanche con che
boccia grazie all'arrivo letto a di
prova si o no
viaggio di buccia da mamma mia sto
veramente sudando e magari sarei
dibattere e basta non fare il pieno
perché di vederla non lo so hai fatto un
bel giro ben 10 che la stazione prima di
tutto non si spendono infatti volete
altri amici
dai bomber un telefono ma poiché la
fortuna di non farmi mai da questi
incidenti questo potrebbe accadere
allora blog
servono allora avevo una botola che mi
ha visto da portare in due
aveva una prima si ok ok sono capite
con i soldi non sarà più niente vabbè
madrid 10 l'altro la r2 è visto è in
scadenza invece a 1 vai
qui sotto
chi non lo è se non quello carlo supino
voti allora prova rientro fai subito
strength e poi contro il grande è ucciso
pure il cuore grana o l'incredibile ad
[Musica]
ti è mai successo questa estate
credo che succeda verso mista tra
l'altro solo per averlo fatto
quasi in salita sta durando gli anni
alla blocco a centi a volo microsettore
l'aveva trovato quel fortunato se stessa
sì la nostra carta da grande mi piace
come sei sincero mi sembravano floyd
turno adesso lo sai tu stesso lo fa solo
da mario mele migliorando
farete prendersi 40 pietra tutte le
forze porca cos'è sta roba che sarà mai
visti
se io non ho mai visto prima
niente
il brutto del giocare con le bombe puoi
aprire tutte le porte però gli dà
fastidio lo vedo così giulio ii vado
direttamente alla lunga ti fidi di me
sento quelli
possono arrivare proprio prodotto
ti spiego come fare sì ho un cuore m
allora a tante fasi questo boston a tre
la prima c'è un nome di post da
abbattere che si divide i due che ti
attraggono luci di quelli a farebbe
cassanata devi ucciderlo vado cuore
perché c'era stata la ormai quanto vuole
sarà normale arrivano degli zoccoli da
sopra ed è lucido anche quelli via anche
se si spara con reset quando mio potere
alla fine cede uccidere questi siti
gg
[Applauso]
amico mio è arrivato molto più avanti di
come faccio di solito crea ragazzi
versate che dopo questo ci sono altri
due da gioco stesso che deve essere
troppo il play se però avete visto che
frivolo e giovinco e di questo però e
scusami se hai visto cotanta anna pagine
però fine del mese invece ci sono state
le stanze dove trave e stavi zitto
esatto i frecciarossa ragazzi io
ringrazio marco bravi fatto un po di
coaching custodia oggi è stato veramente
un bel video è piaciuto mi è piaciuto
quindi ragazzi come se vi fosse un
momento è un bel mi piace anche la
trascrizione lasciato il canale di marco
noi cosa click crew di neuer chiudino
così parlava il ballo
[Musica]